for any holiday it's just a very soft
sweet cookie Oh God that was good
hi I'm Kelsey and today I'm going to be
making my family's butter cookie recipe
it's pretty famous but maybe just in
Indiana so butter cookies are a super
soft very buttery cookie that a lot of
people like to eat during the holidays
when you're creaming together the wet
ingredients you want it to be nice and
fluffy so you get a really good tender
cookie so the story behind these cookies
is actually pretty funny
it wasn't my family's recipe to begin
with it was actually their neighbors in
New Market Indiana it's a small town
where my mom grew up she would have a
neighbor that would make these cookies
and eventually her mother asked for the
recipe and then when my mother got older
she and her sister got the recipe and
started making them and then they've
passed them down to their girls so it's
been a women family tradition a thing I
always look forward to was not just
eating the cookies but also just
enjoying each other's company while
making them it was kind of a thing that
we all got to do with Christmas music on
and we'd all sit around be a machine
just working together to make these
family cookies I didn't know too many
people growing up that made butter
cookies but I hear they're pretty
popular and it's just a classic cookie
just real good the cookies when you're
moving them around the whole time might
be pretty delicate that's pretty normal
because they're mainly a ton of butter
that's a good thing though because then
later they stay soft and wonderful we
would make different colored cookies and
use different sprinkles and different
candies on top I really loved red hots
on my cookies which sounds weird but you
should just try it and let me know if
you like it too and then you want to
make sure that the cookies are nice and
cool before you ice them because the
icing can just like melt um been cookie
so you have to let them nice and cool
and then you have to move fast with the
icing cuz it can set so you can't just
like ice them all and then go back and
put sprinkles on they're not gonna stick
on they're all gonna fall back off I
learned this the hard way
they're best freshly iced or you know
like you can eat throughout the process
which is what being peach okay girls
always do my sister and I
were the Queen's of the decorating my
mom normally kind of put that Duty's off
to us we got very specific and I am very
competitive and I think I am the best
decorator in the family growing up my
favorite cookie to decorate was the
Christmas tree I like to do a green
icing and then I would put little M&Ms
as all of the ornaments I would use the
brown M&Ms as the base a little Garland
pattern or then I would always finish it
with a little yellow M&M for the star
you can do a candy cane a snowman face
snowflake pretty much any type of cookie
that is festive that you're interested
in these cookies remind me so much of my
childhood every year we would do them
and no matter where we were in our lives
we'd always come back together in the
kitchen and make these cookies together
and so whatever I think of the holidays
I definitely think of these cookies and
kind of start craving them I want to
finish this one bye bye
[Music]
this one was a perfect cookie
Oh Bob that was good